Hello, I'm Ron Vale and today I'd like to tell you about
experiments that led to the discovery of a new type of
microtubule motor protein called kinesin. And in this
talk, I'd like to highlight this experiment shown in this
video, where kinesins are attached onto a glass coverslip
and are transporting these microtubules across the glass.
And I'll explain to you why this experiment came as a complete and
utter surprise to us. And also, how this experiment changed
the course of the research project, but also changed the course
of my life and career, as well. But before I go into these
experiments, I'd just like to share some general thoughts with you
about scientific discovery. We often teach that the way
scientific discoveries are made is through a process called
the scientific method. And you can see many different versions of
them here, but they mostly reduce to a similar theme
of first coming up with a question, then developing a
hypothesis, and then doing experiments to test that
hypothesis, analyzing the data, and then coming to a
conclusion. Now, many of the scientific projects I've been involved with
haven't followed such a linear path and been so predictable.
Oftentimes, you get started with an idea, but then the experiments
take you in all kinds of different directions. And there are
various twists and turns that happen in a project. And then maybe
if you're very lucky, you come across in one of your experiments,
some really unexpected result that tells you something very
important and very new about biological systems.
And I'd like to illustrate that with the story I'm going to
tell you. And this story, I think, is very much like a detective who
done it story. Where we started off following, in fact, the most obvious
suspect, but only found out later that that suspect was not
correct, and we were on the wrong track. So then we had to
go back and find new clues, develop new pieces of evidence
put things together in a new way that got us back on the right
track, and allowed us to come up with the correct answer.
And indeed, many scientific projects are really like detective
stories. So today, I'd like to share with you my detective story
that started off when I was an MD PhD student in the lab of Eric Shooter.
And I was interested in this problem of how material is transported
inside of nerve cells. In particular, I was studying this one hormone
called nerve growth factor, which interacts with receptors
at the nerve terminal and then some message must get
transmitted back through this axon, back to this cell body.
But this axon, in fact, can be fantastically long. Even in a mature
motor neuron in your body, the distal tip of that nerve terminal
may be at the tips of your toes, and that axon from that one nerve
travels all the way up your leg, and then the cell body would
be in your spinal cord. So to transport material over this long
distance, there had to be some machinery that was moving material
inside the axon. But in 1983, very little was known about what
that machinery was. But an opportunity to begin to understand this
problem came about actually one floor below me at Stanford, in the
laboratory of Jim Spudich, where a very exciting experiment was
going on between Jim and a sabbatical professor, Mike Sheetz.
And what Jim and Mike were trying to do was to develop
an in vitro assay to study muscle contraction. And what they did in their
experiment was first of all to purify muscle myosin, and then
add that purified muscle myosin onto plastic beads, and then they
added these myosin-coated beads onto actin cables, which were
derived from a plant cell, Nitella. And you can see these beads
or actually clumps of beads, being transported along these actin cables.
And from watching these movies that I saw one floor below me downstairs,
it was very tempting to think that maybe a similar process
was going on in the axons. Perhaps myosin was coating the
surface of membrane organelles and it was transporting these membrane
organelles along actin filaments inside the axon. So Mike and I
wanted to test this idea with a very simple experiment.
Which was to inject these myosin-coated beads inside of an
axon and see if they would move. See if they would be transported
along actin filaments. So to do this, we had to find a good
experimental organism. And we chose the granddaddy of
all axons, which is the giant axon from the squid, which has an axon
about 50 times bigger in diameter than a mammalian axon.
So the next step was to get some squid, so I called the Hopkins
Marine Station in Monterey and asked them if they would be able to
provide some squid for these experiments. And they said sure, we'd be very
happy to do that. We'll give you a call when we make a catch of
squid. Well, weeks went by, in fact, months went by. And we never
got a phone call from Hopkins Marine Station. So eventually, I called
them in June and said, well, where's our squid? And they said,
well, you know we've been trying to catch them but it's been a very unusual
year. We've been trying to fish for them and simply haven't been able
to catch any. And indeed, that was an unusual year, as shown in this
graph of the amount of squid that was caught in California
over various years. And that year was 1983, where there was a precipitous
decline in the amount of squid that were caught. And we now know why,
1983 there was an unusual meteorological phenomenon called El Nino
that warmed the coast of California. And when the water warmed,
the squid just disappeared. So this seemed like incredibly bad luck,
however, this bad luck turned into good luck in the end, as I'll
describe to you. And in fact, it's funny to think but perhaps, a lot of
the luck that I've had in my scientific career is due to this El Nino
phenomenon. Because what El Nino did was to force us to change our
plans and move and do the experimental work at this
beautiful location, which is the Marine Biological Laboratory
at Woods Hole. Now, not only was there a lot of squid at
the MBL in Massachusetts, but there was also incredibly
exciting research going on at the time. Indeed an entire new
revolution in microscopy that was developed independently
by Robert Allen and Shinya Inoue. And what these scientists did
was instead of looking through the microscope with your eyes,
they attached a video camera and also used computers to
enhance the contrast of these images and saw details
inside of cells that were never seen before by microscopy.
And Allen, Brady, and Lasek used this kind of microscopy technique
to investigate axonal transport in squid. And they made these
amazing movies, such as shown here, where you can see
now all of these fine details of small organelles being transported
up and down in this axon. So for the first time, axonal transport
could be directly visualized. So this was all very exciting, but again,
we had some bad news right when we arrived at Woods Hole.
And I opened up this issue of Nature, and found out to my great surprise
that someone else did the experiment that we wanted to do.
They took foreign particles, which were in fact beads, small plastic
beads, and microinjected them into an axon and found
that they were rapidly transported inside the axon. Except it
wasn't exactly the experiment that we wanted to do, because these were not
myosin-coated beads, these were inert beads that had nothing
on them. And in fact, this was a mystery. The investigators
themselves couldn't explain it. They thought, well maybe there
was a flow of fluid going on inside the axon and these beads got
caught up in this fluid flow. Or perhaps myosin got picked up by
these beads. Or maybe they were just piggybacking on membrane
organelles. So they didn't have a good idea of why this happened.
Undaunted, we went ahead and did our experiment with myosin-coated
beads. So we took our myosin-coated beads, added it to the squid axoplasm,
and the moment of truth came, and we saw nothing.
These myosin-coated beads did not move at all, so that was disappointing.
We then still had these control beads that didn't have any myosin
on them, and tried them. And surprisingly, these beads moved.
So we got the same strange result that these other investigators
did, which we couldn't explain either. But what we did know
was that our original idea of these myosin-coated beads
finding and moving along actin cables in the squid axon
was somehow incorrect. So we had to go back to the drawing board and
develop a new plan of investigation. And Mike and I did that by
joining up with Tom Reese and Bruce Schnapp. Tom had a
laboratory in Woods Hole, and both Tom and Bruce were
exceptional electron microscopists. Bruce also developed
a video microscope in Tom's lab. And the four of us worked as
a team to do all the experiments that I'm going to describe to you
next. So first of all, to probe this system deeper, we took
the inside of the squid axon out, the axoplasm, and kind of broke it
apart. And then found out in this dissociated axoplasm, transport
still continued. But now you could see that there were individual
tracks that were supporting this axonal transport.
However, with the lower resolution of this video microscope,
we didn't know what these tracks were. So we had to go to the electron
microscope to get that detail. And Tom and Bruce did this brilliant
experiment where they first looked at a field of view under the
video microscope and then found the same field of view under an
electron microscope, to find out what these filaments were. And then
indeed, when they went to the electron microscope, they found
organelles on single filaments that had the diameter
and the features of microtubules. So the main tracks of axonal
transport, the long distance tracks, were not actin. They were microtubules.
But the question then was, well the motor could be myosin, which
only worked on actin. So some other motor had to be at play here.
And we originally had some hypotheses for what that motor would
be. But those hypotheses also turned out to be wrong. So we had to take an
unbiased approach to understand the motor and the machinery that was
driving this transport. So one way to take this approach was
to reconstitute this system, essentially take it apart, put it back
together again, and find out what was the essential machinery
and perhaps the motor. So we did this by introducing tracks, which
were here made from purified tubulin. We then also took
the cargo, which were the membrane organelles, purified from
the squid giant axon, and added ATP as an energy source.
And we figured that the motors were going to be bound to
these membrane organelles, and when they had ATP they would move along
these microtubules. But again, disappointingly, the experiment
was negative. We didn't see any movement. Well then
we rationalized, okay maybe something is missing here.
Something else is needed. So we added to this mix a soluble
protein fraction containing hundreds of different kinds of proteins.
And to our joy, this worked, we now saw lots of membranes moving along these
microtubule tracks. And this happened late at night, but before
going home, we decided to do what was sort of a boring control
experiment, just to make sure that the things that we saw that were moving were
not particles coming from this soluble protein fraction, but in fact
were indeed the organelles. We mixed everything together
but now without the organelles. So we just added the microtubules,
ATP, and the soluble protein fraction, expecting nothing to
happen at all. Well, what happened blew our mind. What we saw
under the microscope was that these microtubules were attaching
themselves onto the glass coverslip and they were crawling
across the surface of the glass like little worms. And this was,
as I said, completely unexpected. We had no anticipation
that this was going to happen at all. But then in thinking
about this in more detail, what we thought was happening
here was that in this soluble protein fraction, there were motor
proteins that were just floating around in the cytosol. And
they attached onto the glass surface and they were grabbing hold
of these microtubules and then transporting these microtubules across
the glass surface. So suddenly, this old experiment that we did
with these control beads made sense. Maybe these control beads
were picking up this soluble motor protein and then moving along
these microtubule tracks. So we now tested this again
using our soluble protein fraction, and indeed, these
beads picked up a motor from the soluble protein mix and
were moving beautifully along these microtubules. So why was this
a surprise? Well, the reason is that most people in the field,
including us, thought that the motor for this transport would
be permanently bound either to the membrane organelles, which were
the cargo, or onto the filamentous track like the microtubule. But no one
expected there to be a lot of soluble motor floating around
in the cytoplasm. But the fact that there was a lot of soluble motor
gave us an opportunity to think about now purifying the motor
protein from this complex mixture of proteins. The problem was
this experiment happened at the very end of August, and I
was supposed to go back to medical school in two weeks
and start my clerkships. And it would probably be another three years
until I was going to get back into research again. So I called up Stanford
and I said, I had a very exciting experiment and I needed to keep
working on it, can I postpone my medical school clerkships?
And they said yes. So that fall and winter, I spent trying to purify
this motor protein. Now, Woods Hole is a very exciting place, lots of
people there in the summer. And in particular, in the '80s, there
was very few people in the winter. So I kind of had this interesting
monastic environment of just really trying to focus on this problem
of purifying the motor. And of course, it was really one of the most rewarding
and exciting times of my life. So the experiment really was to use this
motility assay in combination with protein purification techniques
to identify which protein of these hundreds of proteins that were in this
soluble fraction was the motor. So you could use this motility
assay for this purpose. So here are different fractions coming
off of a protein column, and here, each of these fractions now
is assayed for motor activity. And you can see this peak of
microtubule motor activity here corresponding to this polypeptide
which had never been described before. And since it was a new
type of protein, a new type of motor, we needed a name.
And a lot of people ask me where did the name kinesin
come from? Well, I could tell you that it came from a phone call with my mother.
And indeed, my mother from the Greek root "kine" came up with
the name kinesin. Since 1985, it's also been amazing to see
how the whole field of kinesin has developed. In 1985, we knew
almost nothing about how this motor moved objects along
microtubules. But since that time, single molecule assays
were developed. It was possible to get X-ray and EM structures
of kinesin. All kinds of protein engineering experiments. You know these
things were done in our lab and many laboratories around the world.
Now we actually have a pretty good idea of how this motor
is actually moving along a microtubule track. The same thing happened
in biology. At the beginning, in 1985, we had one kinesin motor
but since then, many kinesin motors have been discovered.
It's now known to be a large superfamily. They're known to be
involved in many different roles in cell biology, and several
neurodegenerative diseases have been linked now to mutations in
kinesin motors as well. So it's been a remarkable adventure,
a remarkable journey. This detective story that I told you
about had moments of frustration when we couldn't get squid,
we had times when we had results where we simply couldn't
explain, but there were also these fantastic eureka moments that
you really will remember for the rest of your life. And also
an opportunity to really dig into a problem and emerge with
the satisfying mechanism. Now what about my career in
medicine? I never did go back to medical school, I never did
complete my clerkships. And that was all for the best, I've
enjoyed being a scientific detective and I've enjoyed all the
problems I've worked on. And I hope you will enjoy your
scientific detective work as well. Thank you.